لكن الذي تعلمه هو نعلمه جميعا ان هذه
التغيرات العميقه التي ينبغي ان تحصل في
العقود والافكار والمجتمعات لا يمكن ان
يقوم بها فرد واحد مهما اوتيا من قدرات
وانا لست هذا الفرد انا فرد مع غيري املك
ان اعبر عن هذا التشوه لكن هذا التغيير لا
يمكن ان يحصل الا اذا هدات نفوسه افراد
الشعب جميعا وفتح الحوار الوطني نحن نحتاج
الى حوار وطني داخل وطننا داخل بلدنا
لماذا
لم يكن هناك حوار وطني اثناء يعني حكم على
الاقل همم النهضه اثناء فتره وجودك في
البرلمان في في داخل دوائر السياسيه لماذا
لم يبدا بذلك
لم يبدا بذلك لان الناس كانوا مكملين قبل
الثوره
فلما ازيل
المانع اراد الجميع ان يتكلم ويتكلم في
وقت واحد لم نسمع بعضنا نحن تشرفنا
وشوقنا وعطشنا الى ان نعبر عن انفسنا
جعلنا لا نحترم بعضنا والذين يتكلمون في
وقت واحد لا يبلغون ولا يدركون نحن نحتاج
اليوم الى شكل من اشكال الهدوء
ليتحدث الجميع وليفيد الجميع وليسمع
الجميع
هو الذي يساعدنا على استيعاب الفكر
المخالف لا ينبغي ان نبقى نحن كقطره الماء
يشبه بعضنا بعضا لان الله لم يخلقنا لذلك
التنوع هو الذي يمكن ان يقودن الى التغيير
وينبغي ان نعود اذاننا على ان نستمع ما
نحبه وما نكرهه والا نقول الا ما يحب
غيرنا ولو كرهناه نحن